>> I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
HERE FOR INCLUDING BIPARTISAN
OFFICIALS LIKE REPRESENTATIVE
AND SENATOR BRAUN, SENATOR
BEAKERRING, REPRESENTATIVE
JACKIE -- WHERE WHERE'S JACKIE?
SHE WAS GOING TO BE HERE.
>> SO THE UNITED STATES SHARES A
VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP,
WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE WITH THE
REPUBLIC OF NORTH KOREA.
PETE: NEW ALLIANCE.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
RAISING EYEBROWS THIS WEEK.
WILL: HERE TO REACT, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF "COME
ON, MAN," JOE CONCHA.
HERE WITH US THIS MORNING.
>> HI.
WILL: WHAT'S UP?
>> THAT WAS INTERESTING.
WILL WE'VE YEAH.
>> THOSE VIDEO CLIPS.
AND IT'S FUNNY, BECAUSE IF YOU
WATCH, SAY, STEPHEN COLBERT OR
JIMMY KIMMEL OR FALLON OR CNN OR
MSNBC OR A HOST OF OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS, YOU DON'T SEE
THAT CLIP ONCE.
WHICH IS REMARKABLE, BECAUSE I'M
PRETTY SURE IF THE 45TH
PRESIDENT SAID SOMETHING THAT
HORRIBLE, YOU KNOW N TERMS OF A
GAFFE,S I IS HAVE A FEELING YOU
WOULD IMMEDIATE IF ANOTHER
HOUR -- CAN.
PETE: IT WAS NONIF STOP 25TH
AMENDMENT TALK IF HE SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT ON OTHER
NETWORKS.
>> RIGHT.
QUESTIONING HIS COGNITIVE
ABILITIES.
WITH JOE BIDEN YOU COULD SAY IS,
WELL, IT'S BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO
BE 80.
IT IS ALWAYS THIS WAY.
THIS IS A GUY WHO RAN FOR
PRESIDENT 35 YEARS AGO AND HAD
TO DROP OUT.
WHY?
PLAGIARISM.
WE'RE TALKING WORD FOR WORD.
AND THROUGHOUT HIS ENTIRE CAREER
IT'S THINGS LIKE THAT, TELLING A
GUY IN A WHEELCHAIR TO STAND
UP --
RACHEL: OR WHEN HE FELL DOWN THE
SHARES 12 TIMES TRYING TO GO UP
AIR FORCE ONE, IF DONALD TRUMP
HAD DONE THAT EVERY SINGLE TIME,
THEY WOULD HAVE PLAYED THAT
VIDEO OVER AND OVER AND OTHER
AGAIN.
>> AND THIS IS WHY ONE-THIRD OF
DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE IN HIS OWN
PARTY, ONLY ONE-THIRD WANT HIM
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN IN
2024, BECAUSE THIS IS LATE
'70s VERSION OF JOE BIDEN.
IMAGINE IF HE RAN AND WON, YOU
WOULD HAVE AN 85-YEAR-OLD JOE
BIDEN IN THE OVAL OFFICE, AND
THAT'S SOMETHING MOST AMERICANS
ARE LIKE, NO -- THE PROBLEM IS
THE BACKUP IS KAMALA HARRIS, AND
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN NORTH
KOREA OR AT THE DMZ.
PETE: YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE NEW BOOK IS "COME ON, MAN."
IT KEEPS WRITING ITSELF, BUT
TELL US ABOUT BOOK.
>> THE BOOK IS ABOUT NOT JUST
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY, BUT ABOUT
HIS ENTIRE LIFE LEADING UP TO
THE PRESIDENCY, WHICH IS REMARK
BL, GUYS -- REMARKABLE.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO HAS FAILED
UPWARDS HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
AND USUALLY YOU HIT E A CEILING
AT SOME POINT.
HE GOT ALL THE WAY TO THE OVAL
OFFICE THAT ONLY 46 PEOPLE HAVE
EVER OCCUPIED.
AND YOU WONDER HOW DID WE GET
HERE, WHY DID WE SETTLE THIS
THESE SITUATIONS FOR SOMEBODY SO
POOR.
AND THE MEDIA PLAYS A BIG ROLE
MT. BOOK AS FAR AS HOW JOE BIDEN
GOT INTO OFFICE, BECAUSE WE WERE
SO FOCUS ON DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WERE, RIGHT?
THAT THEY DIDN'T BOTHER TO
SCRUTINIZE THE GUY THAT CAME IN
AND REPLACED HIM, AND NOW WE SEE
RECORD HIGH INFLATION, CRIME
GOING THROUGH THE ROOF, 4
MILLION PEOPLE PASSING OVER
BORDER --
RACHEL: CORRUPTION, BEING
COMPROMISED BY THE CHINESE.
THE BOOK IS "COME ON, MAN."
PETE: CONGRATULATIONS.
RACHEL: NEW YORK TIMES BEST
WITHSELLER, COULDN'T HAPPEN TO